das ist nicht leicht worte zu finden für
das was hier passiert ist sie trauern
heute abend und sie sind entsetzt hier
an einem der tatorte in hanau und
überall in diesem land das zeuge
geworden ist wie ein mann aus zutiefst
rassistische gesinnung wie der oberste
ermittler sagt neun menschen erschießt
und dann offenbar auch seine mutter und
sich selbst
es ist auch ein land das jetzt
diskutiert und diskutieren muss in
welchem gesellschaftlichen klima so
etwas geschehen konnte
darum bitte ich sie meine damen und
herren im angesicht des grauens sollte
und in dieser schweren stunde der trauer
zeigen sie rücksichtnahme zeigen sie
solidarität wir stehen zusammen wir
halten zusammen wir wollen zusammen
leben und wir zeigen es wieder und
wieder
das ist das stärkste mittel gegen hass
vielen dank
nachrichten nicht dass leute mit
christian sievers beamtin ein wir
berichten ausführlich über den anschlag
von hanau die menschen die gestorben
sind die hintergründe des mutmaßlichen
täters
und was für deutschland daraus folgt
sport dann später in der sendung mit
kristin otto und rassismus und hass sind
gift in unserer gesellschaft sagt die
bundeskanzlerin heute der
generalbundesanwalt ermittelt wegen des
verdachts auf rechtsextremistischen
terror nach dieser tat gestern am späten
abend als schüsse fallen an mehreren
orten in hanau in hessen
die stadt liegt knapp 20 kilometer
östlich von frankfurt die ersten
menschen sterben gegen 22 uhr in einer
shisha bar am heumarkt hier gibt es vier
tote
der mutmaßliche täter steigt in sein
auto und fährt ein paar minuten nach
westen hier am kurt-schumacher-platz ist
das ziel ein rund um die uhr geöffneter
kiosk dort erschießt der fünf weitere
menschen
die wohnung von tobias r liegt ganz in
der nähe dort findet die polizei in den
frühen morgenstunden seine leiche und
die seiner mutter isabel de la vega
jetzt über die ereignisse in der
vergangenen nacht
es sind die ersten bilder die es vom
attentat gibt anwohner hören gegen 22
uhr schüsse unten an der shisha bar mit
night im zentrum von hanau ein nachbar
berichtet später
ab dann hat man nachbar der pizzeria
gewählt er dann zu beschwerlich deckung
gehen das wird hier geschossen verreist
ihr als die polizei eintrifft und
verletzte versorgt werden ist der täter
längst weiter gefahren in einem kiosk
eröffnet er das feuer abermals und tötet
fünf menschen
der besitzer des kiosk bekommt einen
anruf und läuft zu seinem laden es ist
ein bild des grauens
wir sagen abgesehen fünf sechs leute
liegen auf dem boden zwei hinter der
theke 2 also alles total blutbad mein
neffe beraterinnen mitarbeiter alles tut
auch eine schwangere heißt es seinem
kiosk erschossen worden
der laden war offenbar bei vielen im
kiez beliebt mein enkelsohn hat der die
schüsse gehört weil mir wurde dort in
denen häuser und da ist er hin gerannt
und war aber keine polizei noch nicht
lang krank war und daher dennoch sind
dass unsere freunde alle tod von womit
grand amour täglich am chaos war
eingekauft haben der attentäter fährt
vom kiosk dann in seine nahe gelegene
wohnung dort erschießt er seine mutter
und sich der vater bleibt verschont
die leichen der opfer werden
abtransportiert und ein sichtlich
erschütterter bürgermeister geht vor die
presse
die letzten stunden seit gestern abend
22 uhr gehören zu den fittesten
traurigsten stunden die diese stadt in
friedenszeiten jemals erlebt hat
in den vierteln in denen man sie kannte
wird jetzt der opfer gedacht
wir gehen live nach hanau peter wagner
peter guten abend wie erleben sie hanau
und seine menschen jetzt im moment heute
abend ja vor allem fassungslos die große
trauerkundgebung mit dem
bundespräsidenten ist ja gerade zu ende
gegangen und die löst sich jetzt hier so
langsam auf dem marktplatz auf aber die
menschen stehen noch beieinander
diskutieren sind in ihrer trauer vereint
und versuchen den strecken zu
verarbeiten der die stadt hier heute ein
gesucht hat ihre gedanken sind natürlich
vor allem bei den opfern und 9 der
ermordeten menschen haben
migrationshintergrund hier stammen aus
hama und mein kollege weder tigers hat
heute angehörige der opfer getroffen
sie sind fassungslos und geschockt seit
dem morgen versammeln sich verwandte
freunde bekannte von opfern vor dem
kurdischen gemeindezentrum in hanau sie
trauern gemeinsam die tat ist noch zu
frisch sie ringen und worte
man liegt nichts sagen dem bett weil man
schlafen gehen möchte und dann kriegt
man so ein anruf solche nachrichten und
dann bricht einem so ein bisschen die
welt zusammen eine der opfer hatten 23
jahre alt gerade hatte er seine
ausbildung absolviert nun ist der opfer
einer rassistischen tat geworden
mohammed hat den angriff überlebt und
schildert die minuten des grauens
der mann ist reingekommen und hat zuerst
auf die andere seite geschossen hat sie
alle umgebracht dann kamen wir auf
unsere seite und hat einem in den kopf
geschossen
ich habe mich hinter der säule versteckt
er traf mich an der schulter nehmen
einschüchtern können sie uns nicht sagen
die besucher der türkischen ditib
moschee aber trotzdem ist die
verunsicherung groß
wir machen uns große gedanken was machen
unsere enkelkinder sind 15 16 17 jahre
alt in der schule was passiert nächste
angriff in der schule da haben wir angst
hanau eine stadt mit 90.000 einwohnern
eine stadt mit vielen menschen die einen
migrationshintergrund haben
die tat hat alle erschüttert und wir
gehen auch mal live nach hanau peter wir
laufen denn jetzt vor ort die ermittlung
ja sowohl die beamten vom
bundeskriminalamt als auch vom
landeskriminalamt sind noch vor ort
sichern spuren an den beiden tatorten
und an dem ersten tatort an der shisha
bar am heumarkt wurden vorhin
sichtblenden aufgebaut ist sollte darauf
hin dass dort noch opfer liegen dass
auch noch die toten liegen und demnächst
abtransportiert werden sollen
außerdem wurde die wohnung des täters
durchsucht sein auto abtransportiert und
die gesamte und die kernfrage der
ermittler heute und auch in der zukunft
design gab es mitwisser gab es
eventuelle mittäter oder hat der mörder
von hanau allein gehandelt
informationen aus hanau von peter
wagener peter herzlichen dank und dann
gucken wir jetzt auf die hintergründe
des mutmaßlichen täters tobias r war 43
jahre alt und sportschütze besaß seine
tatwaffe deshalb auch wohl legal den
sicherheitsbehörden sind keine
vorstrafen von ihm bekannt und es laufen
keine ermittlungsverfahren mit
politischem bezug gegen ihn
wie die ermittler tat und täter derzeit
einschätzen erklärt generalbundesanwalt
peter frank auf der homepage des
mutmaßlichen täters
er hatte er videobotschaften und eine
art manifest eingestellt die neben
wirren gedanken und abstrusen
verschwörungstheorien aber eine zutiefst
rassistische gesinnung aufweisen dann
besonders sprechen mit felix zimmermann
aus unserer zdf rechts redaktion felix
guten abend wenn man sich so anschaut
was der mutmaßliche täter da alles über
sich und von sich ins netz gestellt hat
wie stellt sich dieser mann den
ermittlern dar
ja wenn man das liest zunächst dies
bekennerschreiben fühlt er sich selbst
ein als mann der mitte die ein
bürgerliches leben führt abitur studium
aber wenn dann weiter liest kommt ganz
schnell die wildesten
verschwörungstheorien zum beispiel er
sagt dass er schon als baby von einem
geheimdienst nicht nur abgehört wurde
sondern dass dieser sogar seine gedanken
lesen können und diesen geheimdienst den
macht ja auch war alles mögliche
verantwortlich zum beispiel dafür dass
er noch nie eine freundin hatte
dann sagte ich konnte er keine freundin
haben denn der geheimdienst hat mich ja
immer abgehört also hier sieht man immer
ganz klar schuld sind immer die anderen
nur nicht er wenn es um scheitern im
bürgerlichen leben dort geht dann gibt
es aber auch noch eine andere komponente
ganz offensichtlich bei diesem mann
worauf basieren denn die ermittler ihre
aussage dass er eine zutiefst
rassistische gesinnung hatte ja bei all
diesen kruden theorien wir uns als
verrückt erscheinen ist er an einer
sache ganz klar eben dieser
rassistischen gesinnung
da sieht man zum beispiel daran dass er
pauschal sagt dass menschen mit
migrationshintergrund andere ethnien im
grunde nicht so viel wert sind wie
andere dass sie unattraktiv sein dass
sie nicht so intelligent sein und er
sagt müsse alle anderen völker dem
sozusagen nicht weich sind vernichten
also haben wir auf der einen seite diese
verschwörungstheorien auf der anderen
seite ganz klassische rassistische
ideologie beides geht zusammen das sehen
wir auch in letzter zeit immer mehr und
deswegen kann man hier ohne weiteres
auch von einer rechtsextremistischen tat
sprechen zu einer der verheerendsten in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland
felix zimmermann herzlichen dank für
diese erläuterung heute abend wo liegen
die gründe dass sich der hass so
anschaut und entleert und was ist
dagegen zu tun es stellen sich viele
fragen an unsere gesellschaft an die
politik und das auch jenseits der trauer
die es heute auch dort gibt aus berlin
weniger
sie stehen hand in hand politiker von
spd fdp grüne union und linken und
vertreter vieler religionsgemeinschaften
ein seltenes bild und das stärkste bild
das berlin heute abend mit dieser
mahnwache am brandenburger tor von sich
zeigt dieser stille waren den ganzen tag
worte der trauer vorangegangen und
deutliche warnungen
rassismus ist ein gift der hass ist ein
gift und dieses gift existiert in
unserer gesellschaft und es ist schuld
an schon viel zu vielen verbrechen von
den untaten des nsu über den mord an
walter lübke bis zu den morgen von halle
andere werden noch deutlicher benennen
die afd die nicht nur hier im parlament
sondern auch anderenorts rassismus
propagiere
da wird ein klima des hasses und der
feindlichkeit gegen fremde aber auch
beispielsweise gegen demokraten geführt
dass ganz offensichtlich in der lage ist
einzeltäter oder auch gruppen zu
beeinflussen dann zum mittel der gewalt
zu greifen
den vorwurf in direkter mitverantwortung
weiß die afg zurück ich finde es schäbig
so eine furchtbare tat zu
instrumentalisieren alles was wir wissen
ist dass das ein völlig geistes
verwirrter mensch ist von den
rassistischen motiven des täters will
die afg nichts wissen auch deshalb
machen ja andere parteien den vorwurf
politischer arm der extrem rechten zu
sein
es ist jetzt an der zeit dass wir in
diesem land ein aufstand der anständigen
bekommen und alle müssen sich fragen
welche rolle sie bei diesem aufstand
annehmen können
die politik rückt zusammen die afg wurde
bei dieser mahnwache hier übrigens nicht
gesichtet gleich nach unserer sendung
gibt es ein zdf spezial zum thema und
auch maybrit illner diskutiert heute
abend mit politikern über den anschlag
in hanau ab 22 35 im zdf über alle
aktuellen entwicklungen hält sie
natürlich heute de mit einem live blog
auf dem laufenden
der terroranschlag in hanau überschattet
alles an diesem tag aber es gibt weitere
wichtige themen etwa in brüssel
da hat sich die eu einiges vorgenommen
klimaschutz digitalisierung grenzschutz
das wird teuer und das geld ist knapp
besonders nach dem austritt von
großbritannien
wie soll die milliardenlücke im budget
geschlossen werden eine antwort auf
diese frage sucht der sonder gipfel der
regierungschefs aus brüssel anne
gellinek die lage ist so kompliziert
dass der gipfel nicht mit der üblichen
plenarsitzung sondern zunächst mit
einzel- und gruppengesprächen beginnt
beichtstuhl verfahren heißt das im eu
jargon
es geht um diese summe 1,94 millionen
euro für die nächsten sieben jahre
bislang zeit jedes mitgliedsland rund
ein prozent seiner wirtschaftsleistung
ins eu budget doch jetzt fallen die
britischen beiträge weg während neue
ausgaben wie klimaschutz und
digitalisierung warten die sogenannten
sparsamen vier österreich niederlande
schweden und dänemark wollen trotzdem
auf keinen fall mehr zahlen als ein
prozent statt dessen lieber ausgaben
kürzen
der niederländische premier sieht keinen
spielraum ich habe eine biografie von
frederic chopin dabei und ich werde ein
bisschen lesen was sollte ich sonst tun
ziel der süd- und osteuropa ist es
dagegen die förderung von landwirtschaft
und regionen zu erhalten
auch frankreich denkt an seine landwirte
wir werden dafür kämpfen unsere bauern
zu unterstützen denn sie ernähren das
französische volk und europa die
deutsche kanzlerin sympathisiert mit den
sparern möchte aber auch geld in
forschung und innovation stecken und
glaubt nicht an eine schnelle einigung
das ist eine komplizierte aufgabe und
sicherlich müssen da auch große
differenzen überwunden werden streit
gibt es auch darüber die zahlung von
fördergeldern künftig an bedingungen wie
zum beispiel rechtsstaatlichkeit
geknüpft werden soll
dieser gipfel könnte dauern ein
kompromiss ist unwahrscheinlich denn
sowohl die geizkragen als auch die
spendierfreudigen müssen zu hause erst
mal zeigen wie hart sie für die
jeweilige position gefochten haben sagt
anne gellinek zdf brüssel
es war ein spektakulärer diebstahl im
berliner bode-museum vor drei jahren
mitten in der nacht wird diese 100 kilo
schwere goldmünze entwendet die spur
führt zu einer arabisch stämmigen
großfamilie
das berliner landgericht hat jetzt zwei
cousins der familie und einen wachmann
des museums zu mehrjährigen haftstrafen
verurteilt sie sollen außerdem den wert
der münze ersetzen
die münze die big maple leaf mit einem
wert von 3,75 millionen euro ist bis
heute verschwunden
die polizei geht davon aus dass sie
eingeschmolzen und verkauft wurde
plus 86 cent so viel geld sollen die
öffentlich rechtlichen sender mehr
bekommen sagen die berechnungen der kev
das ist die zuständige unabhängige
expertenkommission
so könnte der rundfunkbeitrag im
nächsten jahr von 17 eur 50 auf 18 eur
36 steigen
jetzt sind die länder am zug mehr von
susanne gelhard ob per handy oder ganz
klassisch per fernsehgerät 86 cent mehr
pro monat und haushalt das empfiehlt die
kef berücksichtigen dass es seit 2009 da
war die letzte erhöhung bis ins jahr 20
21 überhaupt keine erhöhung des
rundfunkbeitrags gegeben hat die den
einzelnen belastet im gegenteil es ist
ja sogar eine absenkung vorgenommen
wurden auf 17 50 auf den jetzigen stand
ab januar 2021 soll der rundfunkbeitrag
von 17 eur 50 auf 18 eur 36 steigen
12 eur 78 davon sollen an die ard gehen
vier euro 69 an das zdf knapp 90 cent an
deutschlandradio und medienanstalt
damit finanziert das zdf neben dem
hauptprogramm unter anderem die
digitalen kanäle zdfinfo neo
partnerprogramme die mediathek und das
online-angebot heute.de 469 im monat für
das komplette zdf angebot einschließlich
mediathek das müsste aus unserer sicht
für einen nationalen sender vermittelbar
sein
nun müssen die bundesländer der
beitragserhöhung zu stimmen
wir haben natürlich landtage wo die
skepsis einfach sehr sehr groß ist auch
dem öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
gegenüber das kann ich aber nicht
bestätigen für die ministerpräsidenten
wir alle wissen welche bedeutsame
stellung der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk hat und in einer zeit wie heute
brauchen wir auch qualitätsjournalismus
bis jahresende bleibt zeit über den
vorschlag zur beitragserhöhung zu
entscheiden und damit sind wir in dieser
sendung beim sport und bei kristin und
zwei schönen erfolgen die retter silber
medaille für deutschlands biathleten bei
den weltmeisterschaften in antholz nach
tollen leistungen am schießstand
belegten erik lesser und franziska preuß
in der single mixed staffel platz zwei
hinter dem duo aus norwegen
franziska preuß und erik lesser
strahlten zusammen mit der anteil der
sonne über die dritte silbermedaille für
das deutsche team
dabei hatte sich preuß ihre letzte runde
besonders klug eingeteilt konnte stehend
alle fünf scheiben abräumen und so in
führung es war ein echt cooler spaß
macht erik lesser das comeback geriet zu
einem vollen erfolg gegen johannes bühl
hatte keine chance aber mit nur einem
nachlader zum schluss sicherte er sich
und preuß diese über medaille im single
mixed-wettbewerb von den 30 nationen
waren 20 kandidaten für die medaille
und wir dürfen uns heute absolute die
silbermedaille freuen gold und bronze
gingen an norwegen und frankreich
überzeugender auftritt von rb leipzig im
achtelfinal-hinspiel der
fußball-champions-league dank des
elfmetertreffers von nationalstürmer
timo werner sicherte sich rb bei
tottenham hotspur eine gute
ausgangsposition fürs weiterkommen
die gratulation von jose mourinho an
julia nagelsmann kurz ohne große
anerkennung die sich leipzig aber
durchaus verdient hatte wenn der trainer
schon kein bart hat übrigens sind
senioren haft spielen auf dem feld das
war ein bissel erwachsenen rüberkommen
und das haben die jungs auch gut gemacht
sie spielt nicht wie der neuling auf
großer bühne sondern dominanz louis und
der pfosten sie hätten für tottenham
lange zeit die 0 das entscheidende tor
des abends allerdings erst in der
zweiten halbzeit nach foul an lima
elfmeter timo werner erfolgreich nach
zuvor fünf spielen ohne eigenen treffer
und der erste auftritt der sachsen im
achtelfinale der königsklasse also
gelungen
am 10 märz das rückspiel so viel gucken
aufs wetter das wird stürmisch in der
kommenden nacht mehr dazu gleich von
osten telli ein verlängertes heute schon
mal mit dem kollegen claus kleber ab
21.55 uhr in zdf und jetzt gleich das
zdf spezial zum anschlag in hanau mit
matthias fornoff wir alle von der heute
19 uhr sendung sind morgen wieder für
sie da danke fürs zu sehen in einen
guten abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine neue
kaltfront erreicht uns und sie überquert
uns einmal von nordwest nach südost
dabei sind schauer und gewitter und
teilweise sturmböen
ja und diese sturmböen sind dann vor
allem in der nähe der schauer und
gewitter zu erwarten zum beispiel nach
osten hin
ansonsten ist schnee dabei der bisher
auf 400 meter runter fällt und dann kann
es eben auch glatt werden in den
mittelgebirgen ansonsten weiterer regen
auch im süden die temperaturen dazu
sinken auf minus 1 grad an den alpen und
in der eifel sonst fünf grad entlang der
küsten morgen im tagesverlauf
verschwinden die schauer und
regenschauer allmählich ostwärts im
süden da ist es freundlich mit
sonnenschein in schleswig-holstein
ebenfalls ein paar tropfen
ansonsten recht windiges wetter aus west
bei temperaturen von 4 grad im vogtland
10 grad am nieder- und am oberrhein
die kommenden tage werden sehr mild am
samstag bis 16 grad im norden regen
teils mit stürmischen böen
ja und am sonntag vor allem in der
südhälfte sturmböen und viele regen bis
18 grad ähnliches programm ein wenig
weniger wind aber bis 18 grad auch am
montag ein schöner abend